something we don't really hear enough
when it comes to Fitness and training is
that if you train long enough and hard
enough there's a high chance that at
some point you're going to get hurt
people don't really like to talk about
this because they think it makes them a
bad athlete to a bad coach or a bad
Fitness influencer if a football player
gets a hamstring tear we don't say that
they're a bad football player you can be
the best athlete in the world you can
have done all of your bulletproofing you
might not be doing anything silly but if
you land wrong if you get distracted for
a moment if you're stressed had a bad
night's sleep if you're feeling under
the weather or if you have a genetic
predisposition to tears and injuries
whoever you are you can still get hurt
obviously we want to take every
precaution we can to be as safe as we
can and there are things we can do to
make sure the injury is less likely
however what's really important is the
way that we recover the way we train
around that injury and what we learn
from it to make sure that we don't make
those same mistakes in future don't let
injury become part of your identity and
don't be so scared of injury that you
don't train at all finally if you do get
injured don't beat yourself up you're
hurt enough already
good luck out there guys and bye for now